alors aujourd'hui françois viot françois
diot il était là depuis le début
dans l'aventuré pmp il était au tout
début sur france 4 il nous a menés des
images des télés du monde
chronique on a vite arrêté cinq ans
comme non non non c'est un carton
l'adoré il se déguisait et où il est
exceptionnel françois est vraiment y
voilà les titres directeur de la
rédaction de télé câble sat hebdo
maintenant vous ne venez avec nous et ça
nous fait bien plaisir et aujourd'hui
vous avez besoin de votre avis vous avez
besoin de notre avis vous avez besoin de
l'avis des gens parce que vous êtes un
tournant de votre vie non pas
capillaires les un tournant de votre vie
professionnelle et sentimentale
ça fait dix ans françois que vous vivez
à distance avec votre femme alors votre
femme on rappelle qu'elle est allemande
das appel claudia mais thomas l'amour de
ma vie
l'allemande de ta vie et de la mienne
c'est lourd là c'est sérieux à l'ordre
c'est l'amour de votre vie ça fait dix
ans que vous êtes avec elle sa fédé ça
fait 12 ans qu'on est ensemble et ça
fait dix ans que vous aviez qu'elle
convient entre deux pays l amsterdam et
moi paris d'accord donc là en plus elle
est encore et aussi la semaine dernière
oui elle voyage énormément à votre femme
l'allier à l'étang amsterdam la haye oui
oui elle est revenue à amsterdam et je
n'ai vu ce week-end avait vu ce week-end
donc c'est vrai vous êtes heureux se
voit on se voit à peu près une fois tous
les tous les mois donc on est forcément
heureux c'est un bel amour platonique
bah oui mais pas pour envoyer quand elle
a quand même corriger patate
je regardais voyage arrive pas large et
donc
donc vous l'avez vu ce week-end bout de
la voyait qu'une fois par mois et vous
êtes en train de vous demander françois
dit long je vous laisse raconter il est
en train de poser une question
sincèrement ce je me pose cette question
est ce que je dois tout quitter en
france pour aller la retrouver aux pays
bas c'est une vraie question que je me
pose jamais faire quoi pays-bas vous
avez dans du fromage
j'écrirai des livres je sais pas je
m'occuperai belge ferait un homme au
foyer étonné d'accord ça vous plairait
on est par exemple pas tout le temps
mais quand même vous on n'ira pas ici
aussi
vos enfants sont grands ils sont grands
ils sont élevés j'ai pas eu d'enfant
avec m voilà donc voilà donc vous êtes
vous envie d'être près d'elle vous
manque
oui et c'est réciproque thérèse vraiment
oui elle vous a dit ça ce week-end elle
m'a dit ça l'impression de zen dire on
reçoit mais là j'ai l'impression dites
moi si je me trompe parce que moi je je
connais je connais la vie je connais les
relations humaines
je connais l'amour françois j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu un tournant
ça vous fait rire j'ai l'impression
qu'il veut un tournant ce week end j'ai
l'impression que vous avez une
discussion avec votre femme et que vous
vous êtes dit oui mois contre le monde
entier
moi seul à tes côtés c'est beau c'est
une discussion assez lequeutre en soit
c'est une discussion effectivement très
sérieuse qu'on a depuis un certain temps
et là ça se précise
et ça se précise tout à fait alors
françois viot la question est simple
transphobia doit-il se baril
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces bases il y avait un petit côté
émotion je me suis dit on va bien le
tenir deux minutes en soi non mais
franchement j'adore françois mais alors
françois viot non mais c'est pas des
blagues mais alors ça mais blague
alors vous allez prendre la d re yeux
jean michel qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ce qui doit tout quitter et aller
rejoindre sa femme oui je comprends même
pas qu'il ait tenu dix ans déjà être à
côté d'elle parce que moi je suis
quelqu'un de passionnel donc six mois
est marié avec une aussi jolie charmante
femme que le dollar yen
j'aurais courru hop et des oignons
évidemment depuis longtemps les flippés
désunion ces mauvaises chaussures c'est
votre suite donc moi j'y serais allé
depuis longtemps après si vous avez
réussi à fonctionner comme ça peut-être
que c'est ça qui vous va après est ce
que tu es sûr qu'elles ont envie que tu
l'envoies moi j'ai pas les mêmes échos
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donnez votre avis ni françois liot qu'un
à monaco et en plus elle doit avoir peur
il est beau gosse franchement est
d'ouvrir un mec comme ça a lâché dans
paris je peux vous dire que ce n'est pas
moi je vous le dis je les laissais le
mois du jour vous allez voir on soit
d'être réunies géraldine manier moi je
trouve que tout quitter c'est un trop
gros sacrifices en revanche pourquoi
taper un emploi du temps à partir du
jeudi soir tu l'a rejoint c'est une
heure de train bah oui tu dis jusqu'au
lundi matin avec je peux t'en levée
jeudi soir à une fois pas rejoint une
fois par mois un combat dont plus
indispensable sur l'état
[Applaudissements]
mais je rigole j'essaie d'aménager je
suis un but là pour l'ameublement et
l'électroménager
alors oui si vous aviez du coeur et si
vous aimez quelqu'un vous pourriez la
voir qu'une fois par mois
bah ouais non non non non non non je
pourrais paru temps le l'avantagent
c'est qu'on se régale presque jamais non
plus je m'engueule pas que mon banquier
genevois jamais ça c'est normal avec moi
moi non plus je le ferai pas attendre
vous êtes de la société générale alors
vous avez donné votre avis non pas
encore allez-y ben écoute
non tout le monde ne donnera pas parce
que c'est important mais non là c'est
hyper important c'est que tu es tu écrit
des livres statut peut le faire là bas
amsterdam c'est pas très loin d'ici
c'est quoi c'est combien de ces trois
heures de trois heures trois heures de
train pas comme s'il habitait au bout du
monde à hong kong où house une ceinture
et donc effectivement tu peux décider de
partager ton temps et peut-être même
inversée c'est à dire au lieu d'être du
lundi au jeudi
faire 2 2 fois par semaine à l'ump le
reste du temps là bas où tu consacrera
leçon à l'écriture puisque tu écris et
tu écris bien monsieur est le constat
que j'ai aussi hâte affamés et renouer
des liens que vous avez peut-être un peu
distendues mais c'est un très bonne mais
j'espère juste que la passe barry
d'amsterdam quand tu seras là bas parce
que là les mecs sais pas s il va faire
pékin express mais oui qui dit moi je
pense que tu dois faire attention il
faut que tu te méfies si ça marche comme
ça depuis dix ans tu restes dans cette
situation parce que fait attention
là elle te dis qu'elle pense comme toi
et te retrouver mais elle est à distance
c'est facile de le dire mais faire
attention à ce qu'elle le pense vraiment
qu'elle te dit et fais surtout attention
c'est qu'à un moment donné quand vous
allez vous retrouver ça va chambouler le
cantique le quotidien et c'est comme ça
que deuxième en deuxième
revenez quand vous voyez je suppose que
c'est la fête
[Rires]
et bien je vous propose de continuer
cette fête au téléphone dans la semaine
et je pense que ça va vous savez dans la
relation mais je n'ai soir au téléphone
n'a heureusement fait débat on se
raconte ce qu'on a fait mais ils font
pas des cochonneries pourquoi toi c'est
ça que leur propose non mais oh ouais
mais on est une émission sérieuse il va
pas se mettre le vibreur dans le vrai
zizi par un sabre laser
non mais si oui alors je vais demander
effet connu les deux situations
om et om et ouais mais non mais non
alors on va pas on va pas me dire vous
est ce que vous pensez
chez vous la question est simple ce que
vous voulez que françois viaud a et
rejoindre sa femme
oui oui ben oui effectivement moi je
suis toujours pour les solutionnement
l'extrême donc je suis d'accord avec
valérie et je sais pas moi c'est oui ou
non ce n'est pas ce oui ou non ont
radicalisé suis pas sûr que ça lui
plaise complètement balladur
moitié-moitié maintenant moitié moitié
moi je sais pas à la question paraît
elle est revenue vivre en france était
très bien mais j'aimais bien aussi quand
il était en allemagne mais aussi été
bien en allemagne était la femme de
françois ii
on attendait warren anderson elle vous
c'est moi on joue à la caisse que moi
j'ai pour habitude
et ça c'est mon leitmotiv dans la vie je
laisse toujours parler mon coeur non
mais franchement c'est au coeur il est
donc sage et votre votre coeur et vous
dit quoi mon coeur il balance dans mes
souliers votre coeur et vous dit quoi
moi il y balance effectivement j'ai très
envie de la retrouver en même temps je
suis un peu angoissé parce que c'est
vrai dix ans dix ans comme ça vasant
entre deux capitales entre deux trains
bon voilà avec la clavicule et puis
peut-être que peut-être quand vous allez
tout le temps avec elle peut-être ça va
partir en k4 jamais collé un je
connaisse un rat je te le dis moi je te
dis hein
alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs à barrer vous reste flou
doit-il tout quitter pour aller vivre
avec sa femme aux pays bas oui 70% les
téléspectateurs aiment l'amour bravo
alors françois qu'il pouvait le faire
quel est votre décision
quel est votre décision françois duo ben
en fait je vais faire un peu comme comme
valérie isabelle lesquels ils l'ont dit
c'est à dire que je vais être un peu
plus souvent à amsterdam parce que c'est
comment une étape de notre relation
importante
venez je veux pas la perdre et je veux
pas la perdre surtout donc voilà donc je
vais être plus souvent amsterdam elle me
réclame tout ça quand votre femme vous
êtes à écouter aller la voir
soyez heureux et envoyez nous les photos
mais vous savez que vous saurez tant que
vous restez ici de façon il va faire
sont quoi qu'il arrive de trois fois par
semaine si vous vous ne le verrez même
pas 3 du tram car dame il sera bien il
mangera du fromager pu terminer il va
écouter du diw pu terminer ses fans